I'm going to actually give you a secret
weapon to instantly reduce stress and we
all do this without realizing and it's
called the physiologic side so the
physiologic psy is something that we
tend to do when we overcome a stressor
right so think of breathing a sigh of
relief we've heard that term before
exactly so a physiologic size is just
that but you're leaning into the to the
mechanism so what you would do is you
take a double breath in so you take a
deep breath in through the nose and then
pack it a little bit more with the
inhale through the mouth so just a deep
inhale through the nose and a sharp
inhale through the mouth at the very top
and then you would let that out with a
sigh so you'd go
[Music]
so if you're ever working with a client
and you need to like get the nerves out
of the room or you just need them to be
fully present and pay attention or
you're on a team meeting and the stakes
are high but everyone's just kind of
under a stressful State this is a great
group exercise that you can do as well
so you take a deep breath in through the
nose and then take another packing
breath just fully fill up the lungs fold
it at the top for a pause of about two
to four seconds and then let it out with
a sigh okay and you would do that two to
three times
welcome to another episode of tell me
why I suck where I bring on Experts to
teach me why I suck at different things
and today I've got two friends Sachin
and Deepa who what are you guys you're
like my health advisor spiritual
advisors like how do you how do you even
position yourself it's a great question
we're trying to figure that out as well
because there's no like nice box that we
fit into uh I would just Define myself
as the Eternal student who's always
picking up new tools and new skills and
then paying it forward by teaching it to
our clients so we like to look at root
cause resolution we look to look at low
hanging opportunities for people to
improve their health and wellness and
give them ways to track and measure
their progress along the way awesome so
this is deepa's first time being on a
YouTube video so she's super excited to
be here okay we kind of made her do it
but get it out of her comfort zone is
what we do uh and we're talking about
breathing so
apparently my breathing sucks and most
people's breathing sucks so tell me why
what I'm doing wrong and how I'm
supposed to fix it well I would first
start off by saying that my breathing
sucked as well because nobody actually
taught me how to breathe and it's
something that we all take for granted I
should be sitting more straight looking
yeah it's gonna help my breathing it's
something we all take for granted and
it's because we've been doing it our
whole lives however breath is one of the
most important tools to regulate our
nervous system to regulate blood flow to
regulate our healing uh to improve sleep
to improve mental focus and it's
something that can unlock a new
potential that we didn't even know we
had so breath actually sets the upper
limit of our neurological function
metabolic function cognitive function
sleep recovery all those things are
dependent on how we breathe so we take
about 23 000 breaths a day whether we
like it or not and it's something that
most of the time we're doing
unconsciously unless we're bringing our
attention to it so our central nervous
system our brain stem actually regulates
our respiratory rate and that
respiratory rate is an important signal
it signals our body what state we should
be in should we be in a state of
relaxation and repair regeneration
rejuven Nation or should we be in a
state of fight or flight and so it's
this signal that just keeps firing in
the background regulating all these
processes for us what's cool about our
breath is that although it's happening
passively without us thinking about it
is that we can actually override it
consciously
and so instead of being victims of poor
breathing we can conquer our breathing
and instantly start you know balancing
our hormones balancing our nervous
system sending blood flow to the organs
that we want to send it to sending blood
flow to different parts of our brain uh
should we want to do that get more
creative get more focused we can use
breath to increase our energy and
alertness increase our blood pressure
increase our heart rate we can also use
breath to lower it so depending on
whatever state we want to be in we can
induce a breathing pattern to create
that state in our body all right
exciting so so Deepa how has changing
your breathing changed your life I used
to be a mouth breather so I would say
approximately 50 of the population mouth
breeds and when we breathe through our
mouth we give our nervous system a
signal to be in fight or flight
and so for me I'm more of a type A
personality I get stressed out more
easily and so breath and focusing on my
breath and the way I breathe has really
um I've been able to shift more into
that parasympathetic State and being
more calm and relaxed even when you put
me on the spot to to you know
I feel like really you know leverage my
breath to keep me calm and relaxed okay
so how do we know if our nose breather
or mouth breather do we just know
is there a test now now that I think
about it you know you know mouth reason
is wrong so like
you know I want to close my mouth but
how do we know what we are yeah so
there's actually a few uh signs that you
might want to pay attention to uh so as
Deepa mentioned about half the
population mouth breeds during the day
uh however 65 percent of the population
mouth breeds at night so if a few clues
that you might be a mouth breather one
would be cavities so mouth breathing is
actually the number one cause of
cavities because it changes the
microbiome it dries out our saliva which
causes a concentration of the bacteria
which then kind of eats away at our gums
and teeth so Dental Health gum health
issues those are usually signs of mouth
breathing a dry mouth is a sign of mouth
breathing dry lips is a sign of mouth
breathing people who are thirsty all the
time because when we breathe through our
nose our nose actually recaptures a lot
of the moisture so if you just feel like
you have this insatiable thirst it could
be other things but it also for a lot of
people it could be mouth breathing as
well a clear sign that somebody breathes
through their mouth at night is if
they're waking up really thirsty mouth
is cottony dry and one of the cool
things about breathing through your nose
at night as opposed to breathing through
your mouth is you reduce the frequency
of a nighttime urination so when we
breathe through our nose we actually uh
change a hormone in our body called
vasopressin which regulates our body
fluid and body temperature and so people
who breathe through their mouth at night
are much more likely to wake up in the
night to use the restroom wow
so less cavities if you move through
your nose we all think it's like about
brushing your teeth you recommended me
to go to a dentist who said it doesn't
really matter you can brush your teeth
with water like what I've been brushing
teeth with this toothpaste and it could
just be water and I just need to tape my
mouth and less urination at night that's
awesome I've been taping my mouth
because of you guys and I'm gonna admit
the first night and you just take a
piece of surgical tape and like put it
across actually vertically okay so I did
it acrossed I started that yeah I would
do it like across here but like on an
angle like that but the first night was
I was scared I think that's probably
normal like oh my God if I what if I
need to sneeze cough whatever I need to
whatever and it was actually pretty
rough night but then I realized oh I'm
not gonna die if I do this and so every
night I've been taping my mouth uh going
vertical is easier I used to I used to
get the big one and in the morning just
rip it off and then after three days
like my lips are bleeding everywhere
you're like okay that's just probably a
better way to do this I should probably
like wet it or something first if we're
taking them out but um yeah I would have
really dry mouth for sure I had a sore
throat a lot cavities I can't uh I can't
say that's kind of gotten better or
anything but yeah I've been doing that
every night for I don't know six months
and when when I came over very good I
would like to offer a suggestion for
anyone who's interested in trying this
is that we use three VM micropore tape
yeah so it's a surgical tape that has
pore so it's very breathable and we're
just going to place a little bit of tape
along our lips we don't even if you have
a beard like I do the goal is to get it
on your lips not necessarily over the
facial hair and if it's really sticky
for some people with a sensitive skin
you can just like dab the tape on your
shirt a little bit so it creates less
adhesiveness and instead of taking the
tape off you can push it off with your
tongue but that only does the top or the
bottom you get both sides at the same
time you can with the with pushing it
out with your tongue yeah yep you just
have to wet the tape a little bit with
your saliva and then that because shape
but then only the top comes off for the
bottom comes off okay well then you
might have to just lick that side a
little bit okay or you could just rip it
off and widely a little bit instead of
just the whole thing right across well
for a few reason one is wasteful right
so if your lips are sensitive to the
tape and that could be a uncomfortable
experience having to take it off like
that it's not necessary we're not trying
to do a seal the mouth what we're trying
to do is keep the mouth closed so it
just serves as a cue uh you know kind of
a cue to the nervous system that our
mouth should stay closed other people
wear chin straps so if you don't want to
a Jin strap so the idea of tape can be
like overwhelming to some people what's
a chin strap so a chin strap is is
basically a piece of cloth that just
goes like across like this to keep your
mouth closed does it work just as
effectively
um I haven't used it because I found the
tape is is very convenient for me but um
you know it's some it's another it's an
alternative because you also have me on
all of this organic everything no
chemicals in your bodies and and like
there's residue on the tape that's on my
face every day yeah so you can use uh
you can use a chin strap then as an
alternative if you're interested the
purpose of the tape is just to gently
keep the mouth in that closed position
and you can still talk while the tape is
on you can still breathe through your
mouth while the tape is on so if you
need to sneeze or cough or anything like
that the you know there's enough room
for the for for that to happen okay and
what about the nose strips yep so the
nose strips are a great way to increase
uh if if you have a deviated septum or
if you have uh you know nostrils that uh
can can use some support with
enlargening like mine I have a narrow
narrow nose and narrow nostrils so the
uh the strips kind of open up the airway
a little bit more
so I do that every night
the residue is crazy on those things
though
is there something better that you can
use there is a device called mute which
is actually something that goes silicone
to your nose yeah and I have I didn't
find that very comfortable for me
personally one of the things that I do
recommend is if you are using the no
strips there is two pieces of plastic
that come off right and what I do is I
take one of them and I place it
vertically like this so then the only
place the adhesive is really sticking is
on the side of my nose well this this
part doesn't need adhesive because we're
just trying to open it up this way so so
that little strip in the middle I just I
just uh strip one off put it vertically
and then so there's it just reduces the
amount of skin contact that's taking
place so I I was using the what do you
call it Muse and mute mute it was in the
mute and there's the three different
sizes of them so you have to measure
your nostrils basically and see you know
which size fits best for you
but the Silicon right isn't that like
plastic that you don't want to have in
your nose you probably ideally don't
want anything in your nose yeah right uh
if you don't need it there so it just
really depends on you know if it's going
to make a difference for you so not
everyone needs the strips not everyone
needs uh those type of enhancements it's
only for those people who have a
collapsed uh you know a nasal Airway or
have restricted breathing so if you find
that your breathing isn't restricted and
you can take a deep breath without any
resistance then you may not need to wear
those things so here's what I found if I
wait a week and I don't have anything
and I put it on
it's like oh my gosh it's like is that
this is what breathing is actually like
this is great and same thing with the
mute I would put it in the first time
like that was the greatest night's sleep
of my life this is insane and then if I
wore the day two or day three that it
doesn't feel anything or if I took it
out I didn't feel the difference but if
I took it up for too long and came back
to it a week later like so I just put it
in every day I don't know if that's
recommended or I could just go every
three days or just to create a
consistent habit I would keep it in
there one thing to keep in mind is that
our our nose is actually lined with
erectile tissue so the same erectile
tissue that is found in our genitals is
is very similar tissues found on the
inside of our nose so throughout the day
you might this is relevant well so so
the reason this is relevant is is
because uh the inside of our nose will
expand and contract okay because of this
erectile tissue so there are going to be
times where when you insert something
like that and she knows it's going to
feel like it's really open opening up if
it's if it's congested and there's going
to be times that it's it's not going to
feel as impactful so it could also be
based on how active that erectile tissue
is and we'll talk about that in in just
a minute why that's relevant because uh
what ends up happening is throughout the
day you might find that one nostril
versus the other you breathe more more
clearly through and Alternate nostril
breathing is actually a way to regulate
our nervous system so you can cover one
nostril breathe in and out through it
cover the other breathe in and out
through it and that balances the
hemispheres in your brain balances your
your energy throughout the day your body
is going to do that naturally so one
side will one side will engorge and and
and the breathing will be reduced
through that side and the other side
will become more open so throughout the
day our body is Shifting what nostril
we're breathing through so it so how
much of an impact that those inserts and
the breath work or the breath strips
have is is also going to be uh impacted
by the erectile tissue in the nose does
breathing from one side of the nostril
the other mean anything are you like
more stressed out if you're breathing on
one side does it have any meaning yep so
there's actually a good good way to
remember this so if we want to increase
our energy and increase the activation
of our left brain right so our left
brain is more logical it um it deals
with problem solving so if you want to
sit down do some work solve a problem
then breathing through your right
nostril is is is considered optimal so I
would cover my left nostril and breathe
in and out through my right nostril
think of it like putting my foot on the
gas if I want to go and get some stuff
done then I would breathe through my
right nostril just like the accelerator
on your car okay if I want to calm
things down and get more creative
because it's when we're in a calm
relaxed state that we're far more
creative then I would breathe through my
left nostril so covering my right
nostril breathing in and out through my
left nostril if I want to feel balanced
then I would take one breath in through
my right nostril the other through in
and out and then in and out through my
left and I alternate from one side to
the other and how many breaths do you
need to take to shift yeah usually it's
about five minutes three to five minutes
as well okay minutes
okay and goes by pretty quick so you're
breathing in a four second inhale four
second exhale and um and you know so
pretty quickly you get to that three to
five minute Mark got it okay so how do
we know if our breathing sucks and how
do we fix it
so I know deeply there's probably a lot
that you could add here as well
um but one of the things that we look
for in a client is the state of their
nervous system and the complaints and
the the challenges that they come in uh
to see us with so if you're tired that
could be a sign that your breathing
sucks if you get out of breath that
sucks if your mouth is dry or you have
bad breath or you have dental issues gum
issues that could be a sign that our
breathing sucks another side that a
breathing sucks is if we kind of seem
like we're stuck in this fight or flight
State all the time because our our
respiratory rate will always match our
nervous system so there's there's two
ways that this can happen one is an
emotion triggers a stress response which
then Alters our breathing but we can
always override that by
being aware of our breath and then
realizing okay I'm taking short shallow
breaths I need to improve my breathing
another sign your breathing sucks is you
can actually use something like this
this is a very inexpensive tool called a
spirometer a spirometer yeah so a
spirometer measures your ability or your
lung capacity so how much volume you can
keep in your lungs so this is a great
tool to to be able to measure you know
lung capacity and and to increase it as
well so it's like a little gym for your
for your lungs okay yeah demo for us I
sure can you hit the top is it like that
that thing in the carnival like the Bell
goes off so no Bells but the goal is to
get to the top so the way you use this
and you'll see this a lot in hospitals
so a lot of times if if people are in
the hospitals of the respiratory issue
they'll send them home with this
um but it's also great as a prophylactic
tool so so what are we watching as you
do this so there's
um I don't know if you can see this but
there's uh a little thing here that says
good better and best okay so if you
breathe in too quickly then you'll see
that this this this uh plunger will eyes
too quickly okay this one here measures
volume and we call this an incentive
spirometer because we can adjust the the
amount of incentive we want to give
someone my incentive is always to go
okay what are we going to see this is
something's going to come up yep so then
this little white plunger will will come
up as I breathe so which which about
hitting the top oh I I usually do yeah
so it wasn't always that way when I
first did it I was like yeah this is
hard and then you get better and better
so it's the advanced version of this one
just yeah one that's like this
uh so it looks like a bong but it's
there's no water or anything and no
drugs in it so what you would do is you
would take a complete exhale and that's
actually a skill that we'll talk about
is learning how to fully exhale your
lungs because the reason we breathe is
actually not to increase uh the amount
of oxygen the reason we breathe is
because we can't tolerate the CO2 that
accumulates so our urge to breathe isn't
because we need more oxygen it's because
we cannot tolerate the amount of CO2
that it's concentrating in our lungs uh
so we'll talk about that we'll come back
to that in a second so I take a full
exhale
I think you missed it by like a little
bit it's the nerves of being on camera
okay that was good so you breathe in
nice and slow and then the idea here is
you want to keep it controlled yeah
right so if I quickly inhale then this
is going to bounce to the top yeah and
then that means I'm doing it too quickly
got it uh one of the things that's
interesting about something like this is
you can build lung capacity quite
quickly so breathing is actually really
neat because it's one of those areas
that you can improve measurably uh quite
fast
so another another way to have a tool to
kind of see it what's the benefit of
increased lung capacity how does that
help me uh great question so lung
capacity actually according to the
Framingham study was the greatest
predictor of lifespan so the deeper your
lungs can inhale hair and that makes
sense if you if you've ever
been blessed enough to be present when
somebody is dying you'll know that their
breath is one of the last things to give
out so when they are gasping for error
they can't breathe that's usually you
know makes sense that they're not going
to live very long so our ability to
inhale
um you know deeply is is a great gift uh
to lifespan and life extension wow
let's throw the deeper do you have a
client story or somebody you've worked
with because you work with a lot of
people one-on-one where breath
change their life
yes so we work with a lot of clients
with regards to their metabolic health
and optimizing breathing is one of the
main ways to shift their metabolic
health so for every 10 pounds that
someone lose eight and a half of those
is lost through the breath so one of the
elements that we incorporate with our
clients is teaching them how to breathe
properly and teaching them you know a
lot of the things that Sachin had spoken
about in terms of breathing through
their nose versus their mouth you know
really slowing down their breath so I'm
sure he'll expand a little bit more in
terms of the optimal Cadence that we
should be breathing at to optimize
metabolic health and it's one of the
best tools to shift the nervous system
into more of a parasympathetic state
right and when we're in that
parasympathetic rest and digest State
that's when all the healing and repair
and regeneration occurs but for every 10
pounds somebody loses eight and a half
is through the breath
these are just your clients or this is
in general no this is a fact yeah this
is not it's not diet it's not exercise
it's breathing well the end byproduct of
metabolism in the micro mitochondria
where energy is actually made the two
end products are water
and carbon dioxide because carbon
dioxide is heavier than oxygen right we
pull those carbons out of the system and
then we exhale it so the breakdown of
fat is carbon dioxide and water so the
other pound and a half we pee it out the
rest of it is is through our breath so
people wonder where does the weight go
right like do we poop it out do we pee
it out do we sweat it out you breathe
most of it out in the rest of it you pee
out wow
all right I really want to fix my
breathing
it literally is the most important thing
that we do and you know if breathing
correctly uh also makes a huge
difference in not only cognitive
function but uh in the in one of the
most important molecules that our body
makes called nitric oxide so a nitric
oxide is a vasodilator which means that
it dilates blood vessels and allows for
better circulation the hardest place to
get blood to is our brain because we
were working against gravity and we have
tiny little blood vessels that we have
to go through to get nutrients to the
brain so nitric oxide dilates our blood
vessels to allow better circulation
nitric oxide is also a it kills viruses
and bacteria on contact so we have
nitric oxide that lines the inside of
our mucous membrane in our nose so when
we breathe through our nose we actually
kill viruses and bacteria on contact
versus breathing through our mouth which
is actually the dirtiest part of our
body so you know from a biological
standpoint from a microbiome standpoint
our mouth is literally dirtier than our
anus in terms of bacteria sounds weird
and gross when you think about it good
visual
but it's a different type of bacteria
that's down then what's down there but
it is literally the dirtiest part of us
so we want to take a nice clean air and
we want to breathe out through our nose
because our nose recaptures moisture
when we breathe in through our nose it
pressurizes the air allowing us to have
a much deeper breath it also allows us
to get 20 more oxygen from each breath
that we take so it's it's like
profoundly shifting in somebody's Health
when they go from being a mouth breather
to being a nasal breather wow now you
guys got me on this Ur ring here
measures all sorts of weird stuff half
of which I understand either half and
figuring out is there a way to track
your breath to know like you get some
kind of alert hey breathe is there any
device that exactly so that's a great
question the aura ring does passively
track your respiratory rate so it is one
of the markers that if you look at your
sleep and Readiness score it'll tell you
how many breaths you're taking uh at
rest while you're sleeping a device that
I like is a Garmin it's a Vivo smart 5
and this is a very inexpensive you know
kind of smart watch if you will
um or not it's a fit fit Fitness Tracker
versus a smart watch and it actually
tracks my daytime respiratory rate and
one of the things that it also does is
if it detects an abnormal heart rate so
my stress which means my stress levels
are increasing and sometimes that
happens when I'm presenting sometimes
that happens I'm really excited about
something usually it's more that than me
being stressed out about something it'll
tell me and what that will then do is
it'll prompt me to take a little bit of
a breathing break so this actually has a
built-in breath work app which then
keeps track of you know my every four
seconds it'll vibrate to tell me it's uh
time to either breathe in hold or
breathe out and allows me to do box
breathing without having to count and
just focus on my breath completely wow
and does it does it buzz when you're
getting stressed out how does it let you
know yep it just it just vibrates and
says abnormal heart rate detected okay
and if it detects that a few times it'll
say hey it's probably time for you to
take a breathing break right now if
you're angry and then that thing goes
off does it make you angrier
no
it uh it reminds it shows me and
demonstrates to me that my body is being
affected by this not just my mind and
and my environment or my relationship
depending on the situation that it's
actually poisoned to my body to be in
this state right now nice so you
mentioned box breathing that's like in
for four hold for four Alpha Four hold
four
what are the different kinds of
breathing and then what are the
applications like when do I use box
breathing versus other types yeah so
that's a great question so there's
literally just like there's an app for
everything there's a breath for
everything I'll talk about common
considerations around breathing things
that we're doing all the time and how we
should be breathing so there's a breath
breath app that I use called I breathe
and it basically allows you to set
either haptic feedback or sound based
feedback every few seconds and you can
set what those seconds are so I have it
dinging just very gently dinging every
six seconds and so the best breath that
we can use is called a coherence breath
where you're inhaling for six seconds
exhaling for six seconds and so I don't
want to sit there and count that while
I'm checking my email or doing work I
can just have that dinging in the
background and that serves as a reminder
of what my breathing Cadence should be
there's actually a phenomenon that I
learned from James Nestor who wrote the
book breath called email app
so people literally hold their breath
and they stop breathing while they're
checking their email or while they're on
their computer and so the the I breathe
is just a gentle reminder to hey this is
the Cadence and the pace that you should
be breathing at what's important about
daytime breathing Cadence is we carry
that into the evening so the average way
we breathe during the day ends up being
the average average way we breathe at
night because we can control how we
breathe at night it's unconscious we
have to control how we breathe during
the day so that's six second Cadence is
like a great breathing pattern to be in
throughout the day and Studies have
shown that's what gets our body into a
state of relaxation and um
and but also like you're actively
relaxed versus being totally shut down
another breathing technique that I like
to use is something called ujjayi breath
or Victory breath and this replicates a
CPAP machine so a CPAP machine which
millions of Americans and Canadians wear
is something that helps us breathe at
night and it basically creates a
continuous positive airway pressure
that's what CPAP stands for and you can
use this type of breathing technique to
eliminate the need for a CPAP machine
but also to create relaxation in the
body to clear the throat and to enhance
the function of the diaphragm so it's
really simple you would just sit up nice
and straight and it might be hard to
pick up on the mic but you're
essentially pretending like you're
fogging a mirror so you can all three of
us can try this together place your
tongue gently at the roof of your mouth
keeping your jaw relaxed and closed and
then just take a deep breath in
a normal breath and then now what I want
you to do is as you breathe out I want
you to keep your mouth closed but
pretend you're fogging a mirror so
you're using your glottis wait wait I'm
talking to Great resistance yeah so fire
in my nose yeah
yeah
okay okay he called this ocean breath as
well it just should sound like the ocean
and you're gonna as you inhale you're
gonna take a breath the same way so
you're creating a little bit of
resistance on the inhale here almost
like you're yawning
what's the in out
so this can be four to six seconds in
four to six seconds out and there's no
hold and there's no hold so you're just
kind of going in a in an in and out
pattern okay so the first one six and
six out that's our regular daytime
office working Cadence like ideal okay
this one
or ocean breath ocean breath and what's
the purpose of this one so this creates
a continuous uh positive airway pressure
so if somebody's wearing a CPAP or they
want to improve their nighttime
breathing
um if they have apnea this is a great
way for them to breathe periodically
throughout the day to create that
positive airway pressure and it's
basically the inhale but then there's a
louder exhale so the inhale and the
exhale should be about the same volume
oh uh or same same sound okay so it's
almost like Darth Vader like imagine
your Darth Vader and you're trying to
make that noise or if I like stare down
Nina while I do it doesn't help always
helps when you stare down your spouse
yeah
now what about the box when do we use
box so box breathing is great if you're
if you're wanting to relax so anything
that lengthens the exhale is going to
create a state of relaxation so when you
think about box breathing we're inhaling
for four seconds we're holding for four
seconds exhaling uh for four seconds and
then holding for four seconds so your
inhale effectively is four seconds and
your exhale is 12 seconds
so you're increasing the concentration
of CO2 and then you're exhaling it out
and then you're inhaling again and
you're going through this cycle so it's
gonna that's gonna create a nice state
of relaxation in the body is that just a
de-stress is that bedtime
um you could use it I mean bedtime is a
great time to de-stress for people the
ujjayi breath is also a great breath to
use at that time in the evening breath
we can also use to warm our body up as
well so if somebody's feeling cold if
they want to warm their hands and feet
up they can use the ujjayi breath to do
that too okay so Deepa is nervous about
coming on camera what's your crushing it
by the way right is she coming in and
doing the nostril close to get into
relaxation is she doing the ujjayi
breath is she doing box breathing what's
the well I'm gonna actually give you a
secret weapon to instantly reduce stress
and he actually did it without probably
even realizing and we all do this
without realizing and it's called the
physiologic Psy so the physiologic PSI
is something that we tend to do when we
are
when we overcome a stressor right so
think of
breathing a sigh of relief we've heard
that term before exactly so a
physiologic size is just that but you're
leaning into the to the mechanism so
what you would do is you take a double
breath in so you take a deep breath in
through the nose
and then pack it a little bit more with
a with an inhale through the mouth so
just a sharp inhale through the through
the mouth for a deep inhale through the
nose and a sharp inhale through the
mouth at the very top and then you would
let that out with a sigh so you'd go
ahead
I feel relaxers listen great you could
sell and Sachin exhales as those
ringtoners man and this is what she did
so when you told her we're gonna put you
on she went
so she actually did it without realizing
that she did it and we will tend to do
this so if you're ever working with a
client and you need to like get the
nerves out of the room or you just need
them to be fully present and pay
attention or you're on a team meeting
and the and the stakes are high but
everyone's just kind of uh you know
under a stressful State this is a great
group exercise that you can do as well
so you take a deep breath in through the
nose yeah and then take another packing
breath to just fully fill up the lungs
hold it at the top for a pause of about
two to four seconds and then let it out
with a sigh okay and you would do that
two to three times you want to give it a
shot okay so uh Nina's upset at me for
not cleaning out the dishwasher
I'm very stressed out
[Laughter]
so good my shoulders relaxed too yeah
yeah so you just let that all the way
out yeah and then you know three to five
times and you're gonna feel a big shift
in your physiology
I saw on your Instagram you standing
outside going like this so what's this
what's this breathing all about yeah
it's a great question so there's there's
a few different uh times that you've
probably seen me outside or or maybe not
but uh the exercise I think you're
referring to is when I was in my grass
on in the summer yeah so this is a
technique that we use to move big muscle
groups to increase nitric oxide
production so we call this a nitric
oxide dump and so basically you start
off by doing uh squats so you do squats
throw your hands up in front of you and
you do squats then you stand up straight
and then do front shoulder raises and
then you would from there you would um
do side raises like this okay like a
jumping jack or your uh you're standing
still you're not jumping okay and then
you just go straight up and down like
this so you're basically getting the
biggest muscle groups in your body
you're getting your shoulders your back
muscles your leg muscles your glutes
your extensor muscles and what those
muscles do is anytime we we increase
tension and lengthen those muscles they
start creating a signal to increase
nitric oxide in the body and so when
nitric oxide does is it dilates blood
vessels to bring more blood to that
particular tissue what's the breathing
pattern connected to that so the reading
pattern connected to that would be I
like to breathe through my nose as much
as possible when I do that and so on the
contraction we would exhale
so what that means is let's fast figure
so yeah you're going pretty fast okay
with each movement and you're doing it
uh 10 repetitions of each exercise uh
for four uh for four sets
and that's like first thing in the
morning that's yeah you could do it
first thing in the morning it's a great
pre-workout right so a lot of times when
people take pre-workout uh formulas what
pre-workouts are loaded with to give us
that pump is nitric oxide enhancing
nutrients so because our body makes
nitric oxide especially when we breathe
correctly we should tap into our own
reserves instead of looking for outside
sources of it if we're not breathing
correctly we're not going to be making
enough of it you know throughout the day
not just be not just before we work out
another thing to to note about nitric
oxide is that using mouthwash kills
nitric oxide production because the
bacteria in our mouth is what helps
create that nitric oxide so interesting
enough during
um this these past few years doctors
were recommending people to use
mouthwash to lower their likelihood of
transmitting or getting an infection but
in fact that that is actually very
dangerous and counterproductive advice
because you actually kill your body's
own natural defense mechanisms against
fighting viruses and bacteria
wow yeah I couldn't believe when the
dentist said you don't need to use
toothpaste you know yeah we still do but
we took like the non because there's
something bad and it was a fluoride
there's something bad in toothpaste well
a lot of toothpaste is loaded with all
kinds of stuff right so they may get
antimicrobial so now it starts altering
the oral microbiome that fluoride to it
they add like sweeteners and coloring
and all kinds of artificial uh product
mechanisms that you wouldn't even find
in food right and you can't even swallow
toothpaste because it's so bad for you
but somehow we can put it in our mouth
assuming that it's nothing's getting
into our body I also have glycerin and
other like polishing agents that you
know just are not good for us in in
general so the so we recommend we use a
mushroom infused toothpaste or you can
also use a tooth powder so a tooth
powder can re-mineralize your teeth and
it doesn't necessarily come in the form
of a toothpaste which just to make
something into a paste you have to add
chemicals to it you have to add binders
and fillers and excipients and other
agents to it just to be able to put
something into that format whereas a
tooth powder doesn't require all that
so you put your toothbrush into the
tooth powder mix it around a little bit
and then start brushing yep Nobody Does
this
one other thing to mention about nitric
oxide is Viagra
as an example what effects organs now
we're talking about that well you know
Viagra actually acts on increasing
nitric oxide that's its mechanism of
action what it does is it recirculates
the components that we need to make
nitric oxide it doesn't increase nitric
oxide production but it allows us to
utilize it a little bit better so for
about 40 percent of people who take
Viagra it doesn't actually work for them
because their their own nitric oxide
levels are extremely low and so one of
the things that we use to to kind of
help people understand the importance of
of breathing through their nose is that
Studies have shown that men who breathe
through their mouth at night actually
have lower testosterone levels and have
a greater likelihood of erectile
dysfunction because they're not
breathing through their nose so you know
that should be incentive enough for most
men to make sure they're breathing
correctly especially
wow yeah so I actually we're going from
from erection
what is he bring some so you can
actually test nitric oxide levels okay
so I I know I'm putting everyone here on
the spot but I think it'd be fun to kind
of test our levels okay and see where
we're at let's go and uh there's ways
that you can increase it so what you're
going to do is you're gonna take the
side that says saliva here and you're
gonna put that on your tongue for 10
seconds
and just make sure it's soaked with your
saliva
and we're just gonna see what our nitric
oxide levels are so just yep just put it
down in your mouth
okay and now we're gonna fold the strip
so the two pads now touch okay
and just do that for about five seconds
and what we should see is
this should be pink okay
so the Pinker the better
I don't even see anything
wow look at you like lipstick on
I got nothing did I even do it right
we can try it again but most people are
are like this Pure White yeah like I
didn't even do it
before I'm colorblind but there's I mean
maybe a little bit Yeah but that's how
it should look okay so my breathing
sucks is that what this is telling me or
what does it mean you could tell us that
your Nitric well it certainly tells us
that you're not nitric oxide levels are
not where they should be okay so what I
brought for you is a gift okay
and
what you would do to increase nitric
oxide levels is you would simply take
two of these once a day
so go ahead and take two capsules there
and this will give you the precursors
for you to make more of your own nitric
oxide What am I even thinking
randomly pop pills in my mouth and so
this is a capsule it's made by Berkeley
life and it's got vitamin C thiamin
which is a B vitamin B12 magnesium
potassium nitrate beetroot extract and
fermented beetroot powder so beets are
actually a great source of nitric oxide
precursors okay for our body so you'll
find nowadays natural pre-workout
products actually have beetroot extract
in them so you can eat certain foods
like beets arugula that are high in in
nitrites that help increase your own so
are you taking this every day I do wow
yeah so interesting thing about nitric
oxide is that our levels after we turn
40 literally fall off a cliff so this is
the age where people's testosterone
starts dipping it's like for everything
falls off a cliff at 40. yeah but here's
the thing nitric oxide plays a key
mechanism in all of those things so when
you think about men using something like
Viagra it's all tied to nitric oxide in
fact the very drug is tied to
recirculating neuronitric oxide but if
you don't have any or you're not eating
enough foods that contain it then you're
not even going to be able to benefit
from that medication
and amongst other things so nitric oxide
also helps regulate our blood pressure
so if your nitric oxide levels are low
then chances are your blood pressure is
going to be high because your blood
vessels stay constricted our immune
system you know goes off a cliff because
it's responsible as a first-line defense
against viruses and bacteria if we're
breathing in through our nose the first
mechanism of defense that we have is our
the lining of our of our nostrils and um
and so that's where nitric oxide is is
very concentrated and potent as well so
take the pills plus do a lot more nose
breathing yes and uh to demonstrate this
to my son to convince him to mouth tape
at night tell us your son he's 12. you
think he's 30 though so just from the
way he acts uh very mature like amazing
human being so I said okay Devin like
I'm not going to tell you we'll let the
strips tell you so we did first thing in
the morning breaths uh the the strip
without mouth taping
we did the next day with mouth taping
and it was much Pinker and then we did
the strips after giving him one of the
capsules he's half our size so we gave
him one of the capsules and he could
just see how pink it was wow so if
you're looking to give your child uh or
yourself an advantage in athletics
improving and optimizing breathing
mechanics and then supplementing with
something that increases nitric oxide
will take your performance to a whole
new level wow I should test it in the
morning
yeah one of the big difference because
they tape every night yeah so I've been
talking all day so I'm probably shooting
how do you talk and breathe through your
nose can you do that well I mean just
take breasts well what I drink what I
encourage people do is and I should
probably do this now is pause
and then continue speaking right I mean
sometimes we're just rapid fire and we
keep going yeah but uh we're not talking
all the time so when we aren't talking
then we really want to be conscientious
of that there is a breathing technique
that increases nitric oxide by 1500
percent so I'd love to share that with
you and and our viewers as well it's
called Bumblebee breath or it's also
known as brahmari breath
and basically what you do is you would
sit up nice and straight and I'll I'll
walk you through the instructions uh sit
up nice and straight you're going to
take a deep breath in into the belly
into the lungs keeping your tongue at
the roof of your mouth and then as you
exhale you're going to try to hum at a
at the frequency of your face is the
best way to put it so you're going to
find a frequency of my face yes and I'll
explain that in a second so you want to
feel your whole face and skull vibrating
and because the shape of our faces is
different the frequency that we attain
is going to be a little bit different as
well so I'll kind of I'll kind of do it
and then you guys can can follow suit
and what we want to do is we want to
take a long lengthy exhale
but we want to be loud and proud as we
do it so I'll walk you through it so
we'll take a deep breath in
uh
[Music]
keep going there you go awesome great
job so doing this about five to six
times will increase nitric oxide I feel
like I wanted the frequency of your face
though because we had kind of like the
same yeah it's going to be very similar
okay but what we want to get to is you
want to get to a um the frequency where
it feels like your whole skull is
vibrating okay what this does is we're
lengthening the exhale which is going to
put us into a relaxed State and we're
vibrating the pineal gland and we're
also vibrating the whole skulls we're
kind of waking up that mucosal membrane
so this will 15 extra nitric oxide
production so doing this like sitting
down doing this it would be kind of cool
to see uh if we were able to accomplish
that and see a change in the strips but
remember that the production of nitric
oxide is is very closely and heavily
dependent on the bacteria in our mouth
so somebody may not have either the
precursors or the microbiome in their
mouth that can do is conducive to nitric
oxide production so if you did that a
couple times and you put the strip again
it would test different you might have
to do it for five to ten minutes but uh
it's possible that it would test
different again it depends on how much
precursor you have right because we're
not giving you something to increase
nitric oxide we're inducing the
production of it so we're signaling in
the body that I need to make more and
and that's what you're doing to do that
so if you don't see a change then odds
are that you don't have the precursors
to make it in the first place is there a
blood test for that or or what do you
how do you know if you have the
precursors
um well one is is the strips right if
you're doing all all the things right
and it's still low then we would want to
supplement see if that brings it up
usually within 90 minutes you'll see a
difference so what I'll do is I'll leave
a few strips with you and 90 minutes
after taking that yeah wow okay so
that's how we know it works that's how
we know it's it's doing it's it's thing
got it these exercises are hard to do
too because deepa's got this giant smile
on her face while you're doing it and so
does Nina it's like this becomes like a
try not to laugh challenge as well I
gotta close my eyes
you're so into it and the three of us
who are like smiling
if somebody's watching this and it's
like oh my gosh this like sounds so
complicated compared to what we take 27
000 breaths a day or 23 000. some people
more we actually over breathe as a
society and we can talk about that too
so how to for somebody who's watching us
feeling stressed out and overwhelmed now
I guess you know breathe through one
side and box breathe and calm down but
then what's it what's the easiest first
thing to do to start incorporating
uh a practice
great question so meet yourself where
you're at okay so if you're naturally a
mouth breather then a great starting
point for that person might be to have
the self-awareness that I'm breathing
through my mouth and catch themselves
throughout the day and identify okay I'm
breathing through my mouth let me
breathe through my nose
The Next Step I would say would be for
somebody to be aware of their breathing
Cadence while they're doing work
because if we want to be productive and
do high quality work and be focused and
be present how we breathe actually sets
the upper limit to that capability so I
would encourage them to when they're
starting to do focused work is to First
focus on their breath because that will
then
tell their brain where to send blood it
will it will recalibrate their nervous
system and it'll get them to be in a
more productive state
the next time I would get them to
increase their breathing is is or to
improve and optimize breathing is
unconsciously
which means while they're sleeping so if
something as simple as mouth taping at
night could be a great starting point
for people because they actually just
have to think about putting the tape on
and then they don't have to think about
it after that having those areas of
awareness could be good so when I'm
shifting gears uh what state do I need
to be in right so if I need to amp
myself up there's a technique called
yogurt coffee which I can I can show you
as well that could be a great way to
raise adrenaline a great way to pump you
up a substitute for coffee for example
it's a great way to supercharge your day
in the morning if they want to get calm
and focus they can use a physiologic
sigh to shift gears right to you know
especially if you're going to work with
a client and you don't want to bring the
noise in your life into that
conversation
if you're coming home from work and you
just want to leave it in the car and not
bring it into the house right or if
you're going to the office and you want
to leave you know the stress at home in
the car or at home and not bring it to
the office the physiologic size is a
great way to do that and what I also
encourage people to do is if you're
having meetings throughout the day with
people is bake that into your meeting so
that by demonstrating it to the client
not only are they in a better state to
learn and receive and remember but
you're also in a better state to deliver
your message as well so baking what the
sci one
um you could do it depends on what they
need okay right so you could do
coherence breathing six seconds in six
seconds out for a couple minutes you
could do a couple of physiologic size if
you want you could do the buzz breath
right so you could switch it up between
different different appointments if you
want to but you know ask the patient how
their day is right and then and then you
can choose a breathing technology that
could be most beneficial to them just
imagine next time I'm talking to Grant
Cardone they'll just say okay we gotta
we gotta Buzz breath together and you
need to breathe at the vibration of your
face
great great starting point I love it
nothing cool what's what do you go to on
ongoing like what's the
the breath style here that you do every
day
so the one that I try to incorporate
into my day-to-day is coherent breathing
so I am a it's called a heart math
certified trainer you can set it to
different Cadence and and the main uh
goal of heart map is to get your body
from a stressed out state to a relaxed
state in a very quick time frame the
heart math is a device that you can
purchase and it hooks up to your phone
and it measures whether you're in a
state of coherence or not and the way it
does that is by measuring something
called heart rate variability so your
aura ring also measures it passively but
the heart math device measures it in
real time like this morning for example
I did about five minutes of heart math
and so you're basically timing your
breath with a breath Pacer which is
timed at for me I've timed it at six
seconds on the inhale and then six
seconds on the exhale and when I focus
my breath on that then I'm able to be in
a state of high coherence which allows
me to be in a more calm and relaxed
State heart math is an institution
that's done a lot of research as well
and it's shown to be able to decrease
anxiety decrease depression helps
improve sleep helps improve focus
helps improve attention and mental
Clarity so it's a great device that you
can purchase to actually objectively
measure whether you're in that state of
high coherence and whether you're in a
parasympathetic state or not and then
it'll show you your HRV yep it shows you
your HRV because you guys have said my
HIV socks
right what am I at I'm at like a 40 or
something I need to be at the 80 what
what if I figure what my data is like
but it's not very good so just to be
clear I never said it sucks okay uh I
would say there's room for improvement
well okay you're being kind
you know the show is telling me why I
suck so yeah
the one thing I'll say is that your aura
ring is measuring your HRV uh passively
yeah so it's measuring it while you're
sleeping uh whereas uh the heart math is
is almost like a hrb gym so it's
teaching you what breathing pattern is
going to help you increase your heart
rate variability and get into a state of
coherence it's like almost like a gym to
strengthen uh HRV HRV I should also
mention is a relative term so I'm not
like we shouldn't compare ours to each
other like all three of us are going to
have different kind of HRV readings but
the goal is to always work on getting it
better so heart rate variability it's
the it's the time between your heart
beats yes and the idea is to make it as
high as possible so that your heart is
beating slower
great okay that one took me forever to
figure I don't know why like why is why
is higher better I don't understand but
it's the time between the beats and so
the best way for me to not suck at HRV
is to do heart Math training I would say
so
all right to raise it would be heart
Math training yeah we also find other
ways uh that we see people's HRV going
up passively like fasting so a lot of
times when people go on a extreme
fasting protocol they'll notice that
their HRV uh starts to increase if they
incorporate intermittent fasting or they
avoid late meals they'll notice that
their HRV increases sometimes we have
like just background noise stress that's
going on in our lives we just have a lot
on our plate and and so under times of
duress and stress or illness we'll see
people's HRV start to tank so we're
always looking for Trends so you might
start let's say in the 40s and the goal
is like how do we Trend that upwards if
we're seeing opportunity for improvement
and where should I be
you should be where you need to be so
again what did you tell me on the call I
need to be like well I'm here I say I
like to see it at least above 60 right
closer to us is that not closer to 100
is that not a big deal like if I'm at 40
I need to more than double
is that not a big deal or is that like
the changes happen fast I mean I think
the it feels like it's giant you're
doing a lot of the right things right
but I still don't know
is it a big mountain to climb or that's
actually it could be like one of the
things that we see is is When people's
hrvs tend to stay on the lower side is
that they are and this isn't directed at
you but this is just general observation
is that they don't recover very well so
it's it's their push push push go go go
and then their body is is they're
pushing themselves too hard either
physically mentally emotionally during
the day that they're not able to get
into that deeper relaxed State like
during sleep or just in general so
there's a breathing signature that we
have during the day that carries forward
in into the evening right so if we're
kind of uh wired stress like shallow
breathing or not conscientious of how we
breathe during the day our HRV is going
to be all over the place which means
that at night it's probably going to be
on the lower side as opposed to being on
the higher side so it what we do during
the day carry forwards into our evening
how big a mountain am I trying to climb
like if if I was trying to lose more
than half of my body weight like that's
a big deal right so going from 40 to 100
is that is that a Giant Mountain it
might have to be like an Olympic Athlete
to do that or is that that's doable I
don't think they get the 80 is pretty
easy I mean I have some thoughts I love
your thoughts
I think as Sachin said it we don't want
to compare ourselves to others like
everyone's HRV is unique but he told me
I need to be at 100. I was basically
telling me I suck here it's just how I
don't I'm trying to understand how big
of a journey is that is that hey if I
did heart math for 10 minutes a day for
the next year I'll get to like six till
well so HRV is is measuring your
resiliency distress and stress doesn't
always come in emotional you know
emotional stress right stress is
physical chemical emotional so if you're
exposed to a lot of toxins uh if you
have parasite overgrowths or bacterial
overgrowths which is a whole nother like
rabbit hole to go down
um that's a stressor on the body right
so there's so many different stressors
on the body that can impact HRV even
emotional stress traumas uh even
something perhaps from our childhood
that's you know unresolved trauma that
we haven't uh dealt with can can impact
your overall resiliency to stress should
I always be sick like should I be dead
or something here how about 40. I mean
I've seen hrvs in the 18s so I don't
think yeah yours is not in the toilet
okay
are overweight it just as a general rule
right so like most people aren't healthy
sometimes there's a difference between
our physical health yeah and our nervous
system health
so somebody who's thin uh and even
muscular can be just totally jacked up
when it comes to their nervous system
right so there's people who are thin and
skinny and even physically fit they're
anxious all the time
that have toxic breathing patterns that
are just raging all the time right
either internally or externally
and there's people that you know let's
say are overweight or maybe don't have
the most desirable body composition that
are calm relaxed peaceful a joy to be
around right they're happy they go lucky
They're laughing right and and they have
a good energetic signature a good Aura
to be around so we don't always want to
correlate somebody's physical appearance
in the nervous system health because
sometimes that could be a little bit
misleading sure obviously in general
like averages most people are overweight
I would I would suspect most people's
HIV socks yeah I mean I mean here's the
thing we're looking for trending right
so if we see that hey you're
consistently in the 40s right and you're
doing a lot of the right stuff then hey
that's great let's see if we can Trend
it upwards but we're more concerned when
it starts trending downwards right
because then we're picking up a signal
that something isn't quite right so when
somebody gets like you know we've seen
over the last few years when people get
coveted or when they're there's a
disease or illness that's kind of on
setting and we'll see like their HRV
will will nose dive usually before they
get symptoms
because their body's responding and
that's like something that we'll see and
then the symptoms will show up a little
bit afterwards I think the thing for you
to look at maybe on your aura ring is uh
you can look at HRV and you look you can
look at the trend in terms of what your
HIV is on a day-to-day basis week to
week basis and month-to-month basis so
you should maybe look at the trend on a
month-to-month basis and see if you've
seen an upward trajectory from when you
first started wearing it like sometimes
you know it's going to vary right like
if you got sick let's say in December it
might have you know taken a bit of a
nosedive but in general from where when
you started wearing the ring and you've
made a lot of differences in your health
have you seen a little bit of an
increase so that's what you want to kind
of look out for like you know when we
work with our clients we have them
really try to pay attention to that
number to see if they're seeing a trend
in terms of it improving when they start
working with us and for most of our
clients they'll see that upward trend so
that's kind of what you want to look at
so I just a high functioning anxiety
person or so I don't remember why
I don't feel stressed out I don't think
we have a lot of toxins you know we
don't eat we eat pretty clean everything
um but if I'm you know in the 40s am I
just dealing with some trauma or anxiety
pretty well and just handling it or it's
all relative so you and I were to switch
roles in life right we were to swap each
other's uh lives out I might find your
life very stressful
right you've adopted and adapted to that
level of stress or the opposite could be
true as well you might be like holy how
does he do this right but I haven't
adapted to it if I if I'm so low on the
HIV right I mean my body is telling me
you're not recovering
yeah I mean you could be overly active
during the day right or there may not be
enough downtime in your day I know you
spend a lot of time on the rebounder
yeah right so maybe maybe that's
creating uh you know
um a trend in your nervous system that
is is carrying that signature into the
evening so maybe might be worth maybe
for a few days not rebounding and seeing
what happens because there's a lot of
caloric expenditure that you're moving
out right okay
all right I gotta well I gotta figure it
out okay so what what would my heart
Math training be
I want to improve my HRV I want to go to
the gym for my
not my heart my I guess my heart what am
I doing what's my protocol I would say
like uh whatever time of day is best for
you or whatever time of day you feel
like you need to get more into that rest
and digest it usually for me personally
I like to do it first thing in the
morning
um but if that's first thing in the
morning or before bedtime is just use it
for about five minutes like interesting
in the morning like let's go
[Laughter]
yeah probably better at night
so you yeah so then at bedtime just I
would just start with about two to five
minutes
and 25 minutes a day six in six out yeah
okay and I'm trying to keep it in I
forget are you trying to keep it in the
zone right you're trying to keep it you
know visually speaking uh in the green
like when you're using the app it'll be
in you you want to be in the green as
much as possible and you can notice how
sometimes when your thoughts stray if
you're thinking about something
stressful your HRV might take a nosedive
you might go into the red
um so you can play around with it that
way as well is it kind of like that what
was that old headband that would measure
it's like news news yeah we hear the
birds or the or the thunderstorms this
is silent you can play a track in the
background if you like the same kind of
way no so it doesn't give you auditory
feedback like Muse I actually found that
very distracting uh personally it's more
like what it's measuring though like
it's measuring yeah that brain activity
yes exactly yeah so it's measuring
something different okay yeah I mean
here's the thing though when we do get
into coherence uh our brain and our
heart are communicating much more
efficiently so you know there's a saying
that the longest journey you'll take is
a journey between The Head and the Heart
and that's what heart math helps us do
it helps us kind of walk that I like
having indicators I like having targets
I'm competitive and even with myself
just like yes I'm crushing this problem
how long does some of this stuff last so
I mean you know like they exhale the
Sigh that gives you I guess a few
moments of instant relief if you gotta
go do something but if you're doing
something prolonged like if you're doing
if you tape your mouth and you're
sleeping for eight hours
and you used to be a mouth breather how
much of an effect does that have
during the day is like the whole day is
it the if you just go back to melt breed
as soon as you wake up does it the
benefits wear off like how much of a
what's the half-life of this stuff the
honest answer is I don't know and it's
going to vary from person to person
depending on other metabolic factors
right so uh you know breathing can can
do so much for us but so can nutrition
so can lighting so can other other you
know action steps that we can take I
would say that the thing that many
people don't do well is sleep well and
we found a lot of times their sleep or
poor sleep is associated dysfunctional
nighttime breathing
so 65 million or 65 percent of people
breathe through their mouth at night so
a very low hanging opportunity for most
people 65 million Americans snore at
night 22 million have apnea which means
actually literally stop breathing at
night
so how we breathe unconsciously during
the day and at night actually sets the
upper limit of our metabolic health so
you can't be healthier than how you
breathe unconsciously because you're
taking 23 000 breaths a day it's the one
thing that we can actually control it's
the bridge between our sympathetic
nervous system and our parasympathetic
nervous system it regulates our
circulation the diaphragm which is the
muscle that separates the trunk organs
and the lungs and the heart is referred
to as a second heart it's also the
master pump of the lymphatic system so
when we breathe correctly throughout the
day and our diaphragm moves up and down
the way it's supposed to it takes all
the toxins and moves them from our
organs in our trunk there's so many
things that happen when we breathe
correctly like breathing correctly in my
opinion is the first step towards Better
Health and for most people especially
when they come to us it's the last thing
they've heard of everyone's changed
their diet everyone's you know you know
exercise more even with dysfunctional
breathing right they get results but
they will get better results if their
breathing was functional a lot of people
change their diet we've heard about the
alkaline diet right like eat food foods
that are alkalizing to your body the
most alkalizing thing that we do is
breathe correctly your lungs are the
most important organ in regulating
alkalinity of your blood more so than
your diet so these are important things
to understand because if we breathe
correctly then it's the first Domino
that knocks down everything else our
cognitive function improves our
circulation improves our heart doesn't
have to work as hard our blood pressure
normalizes we don't have imbalances in
cortisol and other stress hormones our
digestive organs our liver our kidneys
our reproductive organs start working
better our Sexual Health improves
because we're producing more nitric
oxide our focus our cognition starts to
improve dramatically our recovery from
exercise also improves how we sleep
improves there's just so much that it's
tied to it's it's literally the one
thing that's connected to every system
and cell and tissue in your body and if
we can get people to see that and
recognize it sometimes it's it's not the
most sexiest intervention because we
don't have to like pop a pill or inject
anything into you and but it is
unequivocally the thing I can say that
has the biggest impact on somebody's
Health man that's why I wish there was
some kind of device I guess the watch is
the best
chance to tell you when
when you suck you know that one's
measuring your heart rate and telling
you need to breathe more Yep so it's
it's actually measuring right now it's
measuring my heart rate it's measuring
it's giving me a body battery right so
just like our phone when we charge it in
the morning yeah uh you know it runs out
depending on how we use it and so it's
telling me what my body battery is it's
telling my heart rate right now it'll
detect if my heart rate goes abnormal
so if I'm just sitting still and my
heart rate starts you know elevating
it'll detect that because maybe I'm
doing something that's stressing me out
and then if if I consistently do that
throughout the day it's going to say Hey
you probably need to take a breathing
break here so it's a great reminder
um and it's also measuring my
respiration as well my breaths per
minute
does this give you a notice it doesn't
tell you if you're breathing and heart
rate become irregular based on your
movement so if I'm moving it it's going
to expect me to breathe more but if I'm
sitting still and I start breathing
excessively or my heart rate goes up
then that's when I get the warning it's
like if you're breathing 23 000 times a
day a lot of them probably suck right
and just having
some kind of alert or notice like when I
got used to barefoot walking right
if you heal strike like you do in a
normal shoe it hurts yep and it forces
you to walk properly
because if you don't it's Gonna Hurt
where there's you can't feel the
immediate hurt of a bad breath
and so some kind of I guess I don't know
something kind of such an invention for
somebody to help me breathe better and
give you some kind of alert it's like
okay it's like yeah you got to fix this
so I like the I breathe because you can
set a little you know tone every six
seconds and you'll always kind of find
your way back to that Cadence the mouth
breathing or the mouth taping guarantees
that you're breathing better at least
while you're sleeping another thing that
some people will do is they will mouth
tape during the day so if you're not on
camera or anything like that you can do
that you can also get mouth guards that
you can wear that seal your mouth so
that it again forces You to Breathe In
and Out through your nose and I think a
lot of it starts by just having that
self-awareness so to get used to it
um like what to to like if okay so if
you forget the tape
do you just go back to mouth breathing
or are you are you used to it so there's
techniques to breathe better at night
and
um you know one is is posture so it's
always best to sleep on our left side
that's the ideal position to sleep in
about stomach it's like the worst well
stomach is good too okay it's just it
forces your neck to be turned to one
side so you know depending on uh some
people may not feel comfortable with
that but sleeping on your left side is
is a great position to sleep in because
it helps improve and optimize
circulation and it prevents the airway
from collapsing
so when people sleep on their back what
happens is their neck goes like this and
their Airway Kings so now their
breathing becomes restricted that's Lena
and that's what makes it hard for them
to to breathe
um to breathe through their nose because
breathing through our nose naturally
feels restrictive and the reason for
that is actually physical because we're
pressurizing the air so when we breathe
through our mouth there's no resistance
because there's nothing pressurizing the
air as it goes into the lungs when we
breathe through our nose we're
pressurizing the air which allows us to
take a deeper inhale and that deeper
inhale allows us to take more cleansing
breaths as well so most of the CO2 is
kind of stuck at the bottom of our lungs
and if we're if we're breathing through
our mouth throughout the day we're just
packing the air down there and the CO2
kind of gets trapped it doesn't
circulate as as well as it should so by
taking some cleansing breaths you know
in through the nose and you can blow out
through the mouth if you want
but um that can be that can make a big
difference for a lot of people from the
four positions what's best to worst
um back is worst back is worse than that
because okay I mean and here's the thing
the worst position is the one that's
uncomfortable for you okay right so if
somebody's gotta Bust It Up left
shoulder laying on their left side is
probably not an option ideally left side
down is best
that I would say right side down and
then sleeping on your stomach would
probably be for some people that's very
comforting so they just feel very
exposed and uncomfortable when they
sleep on their back okay
um and childhood trauma
possibly it could possibly be could be
something pre-verbal too right that you
don't even you can't even cognize or
recognize that this is something that
happened because you didn't know words
at that time when that happened so that
is a possibility I'm not saying that's
the case and then I would say that the
worst is probably sleeping on on your
back okay
particularly from a Airway perspective
if you do sleep on your back and that's
comfortable for you then you want to try
to have a very small pillow or no pillow
at all for your neck yeah got it
I was talking
and he said breathe through your nose
but he said tape your mouth when you're
working out
and I tried and and the weights is fine
but the cardio he's like tape your mouth
when you're doing cardio too I'm I like
five minutes in I can't I'm like I'm
dying I feel like I'm gonna pass out so
I have to the first five minutes I can
do in and out through the nose second
five minutes I'm in through the nose out
through the mouth and then after that
I'm like full I'm out breathing the
whole it's just I can't even try anymore
so how do I that sounds like a really
hard thing to do was but he trains
athletes if I'm gonna go for a half hour
run
how do you breathe is it just practice
or is there a technique to am I taking
in too much air am I like what do I yeah
wrong so there's three years of
breathing okay which you which you
alluded to so gear number one is
breathing in and out through your nose
gear number two is in through the nose
out through the mouth and the third gear
is full out Sprint right and it's going
to be in and out through the mouth and
we want to kind of uh recognize what
gear we're in and what gear is necessary
uh once we start breathing once we start
breaking that pattern of breathing
through our nose then we've likely
exceeded our metabolic capacity because
just like an exercise if your form
breaks down then you're beyond even
though you might be able to lift that
weight and get it up off the ground uh
you've exceeded your capacity to lift
that weight with correct form so what
might benefit you is is slowing down
your breathing it sounds paradoxical
to slow your breathing down because we
want to we want to breathe more to get
in more oxygen but just realize that
it's the concentration of CO2 that's
what's causing the urgency to breathe so
if you can take cleansing breaths and
get as much air out of your lungs as
possible and then let that CO2
concentration increase what that does at
a tissue level is you get more oxygen
dumping at the tissue so interestingly
enough we have this beautiful survival
mechanism it's called a boar effect
which means that as CO2 concentrations
increase more oxygen is delivered to the
tissue so it like imagine if we stop
breathing we want that to happen right
we want we don't want to have to depend
on breathing to get oxygen to the tissue
we already have enough oxygen we just
need to create a signal that dumps it to
the tissue and that's what carbon
dioxide does so
one of the things that I would suggest
to you is increasing your CO2 tolerance
so the way you do that is by walking and
plugging your nose so I'll give you a
simple example but also not breathing
through my mouth yeah so so here's what
we do so because the urge to breathe
comes from look at the pressure
because the urge to breathe comes from
CO2 concentrations knowing that we can
actually build up resilience we can
actually build up tolerance to high
levels of CO2 and kind of get used to
that feeling so we don't over breathe so
what you would do is you'd go for your
regular walk and you and Nina enjoy
several walks throughout the day and
what you would then do is you would take
a few cleansing breaths so deep inhales
deep exhales let it let the air all the
way out do about two or three of those
and then you take a deep inhale and a
relaxed exhale so the relaxed exhale is
upon which you would then plug your nose
close your mouth and you would take as
many steps as you can
now you would unplug your nose when you
feel a strong urge to breathe but you
never want to get to the point where
you're gasping for air so you wouldn't
want to break it with like
you would just want to be able to gently
reclaim your breath and so doing that
day in and day out you're going to start
building up that CO2 tolerance is when
I'm walking or just in general just in
general but especially when you're
walking that's a good time to do it
because you can count your steps and
that's a kind of a way to measure right
so each day you can measure another way
to measure your breathing capacity
something called a bolt score and I know
Patrick may have talked about this with
you so it's called the blood oxygen
level test and essentially what you
would do you do this in the morning
before you get up and get out of bed you
would take a few cleansing breaths and
you would exhale gently so you know a
relaxed exhale we call it plug your nose
and then you would time yourself so you
know some people they can't even get to
20 seconds without having to gasp for
air you'd want to get to a point where
you're that first urge to breathe the
clock's done
and you want to build up to about 45
seconds another way to increase CO2
tolerance Devin and I my son do this
exercise in the car is you would take a
deep inhale and then you would do a slow
nasal exhale so you would try to Exhale
from your nose as slowly as you possibly
can and you try to get over 60 seconds
so I can get up to about a minute and 37
seconds it just has a benchmark not as
um
you know maybe it's a gamification thing
we can we can see who can who can
outperform one another it'll take a
while to get there but uh but you would
just slowly exhale uh through your nose
you're not buzzing or anything again
that's building up that CO2 tolerance if
I'm sliding out my breathing while
running is it slow in and slow out or
just slow out probably slow out is is
gonna get you the most benefit because
again that's going to increase the the
CO2 concentrations the most and you know
just going back to to all of this to the
beginning is you still have three gears
yeah right so it's okay to use that
third gear if you need it right but if
you if you want to build up more
tolerance otherwise I die
it's like I can't breathe well we need
to right if a lion's facing us or we're
sprinting full out then then yeah you'd
want to do that right if burglar is
chasing you you're not going to be
focused on nasal breathing right because
you just want to get out of that
situation yeah
all right so you have a breathing
exercise for us
oh take us through some guided breathing
what what do you want to pick what are
we going to do I'll close my eyes and
you can take it through because people's
gonna make me laugh or Nina one of the
two of them so there is a technique that
I use and it's uh it's called the
elemental Rhythm uh breathing technique
and or breath work experience normally
the way we do this is is set to music
and there's
um you know about six rounds of
breathing that we go through but once
you get really good at it it doesn't
take six rounds to get you into what we
might describe as an altered state and
there is there's actually four different
uh five different techniques that we
combine into this breathing session
the first is coherence breathing so six
seconds in six seconds out so we would
find that pace of six seconds in six
seconds out and then we would take a
two-step breath so we would inhale to
our bellies and inhale to our chest and
then exhale with a two step so it'd be
like
so it's like a circular breathing we're
breathing in through our nose and out
through our mouth the reason we're doing
that is because we want to move a lot of
volume so the idea here is is we're
doing this temporarily this isn't how
you breathe throughout the day
and then we do that for about a minute
or two and then we'd increase the pace
to go in and out so be
and then we would do something called
Breath of Fire where we'd be breathing
as fast as we can and just really
breathing into our throat so it would
look like this
and then I would ask you to take a full
exhale
let it all the way out take a deep
breath in
and then we're going to hold that at the
top as long as we can and generally
speaking you know you can get up to a
few minutes at that point and then we
would do a buzz breath exhale so we
would then do a burmary breath fully
exhale buzzing our face as as we did
keeping our tongue at the roof of our
mouth exhaling through our nose and we
would then fully fully exhale buzzing
for as long as we can
and going all the way to empty okay so
that would end the routine
I'll just I forgot some of that so and
just follow your lead you tell me what
to do and so I can Guide You Through It
generally speaking we want to set an
intention into this so you might want to
set an intention uh a lot of times when
we do this type of breath work it's
important to come back to that intention
and and and to the intention could be
something that you're grateful for the
intention could be a problem that you're
trying to solve it could be
you just saying shut up and let's
breathe okay so figure out what that is
for that last one
figure out what that is for you let's
take a set of nice and straight and
comfortable really and let's breathe in
through the nose for a count of six five
four three two one exhale five four
three two one inhale five four three two
one exhale five four three two one
inhale
exhale
exhale feeling that air moving through
your body
beautiful inhale
exhale
inhale
we'll take a few more inhale
exhale
one more full round inhale and then
we're going to pick up the pace
exhale we'll take a double breath into
the belly and lungs double breath out
through the mouth breathe in sharp
breath in
out through the mouth
all right
keep that pace
foreign
more seconds
the intentional be deep be Sharp
sharper
deeper
follow that intensity
there you go
over to pick up the pace one more time
on a count of three
two one
foreign
sharp intentional keep going
30 more seconds let's go in out thin out
in out in out
in out in out in out in out in out in
out in out in out in out in out feel it
keep going
foreign
sharp as deeply and sharply as you can
that's it
give me 10 more seconds
and then we're going to go in and out
through the mouth as fast as you can in
five four three two one let's go
as fast as you can in and out through
the mouth
keep going
20 more seconds you got this
keep going keep going
ten more
five more let's go
okay breathe all the way out
take a deep breath in
through the nose fill the belly fill the
lungs feel the upper part of the lungs
and hold at the top and as you're doing
that I want you to squeeze your pelvic
floor the same muscles you would use to
stop yourself from peeing
as our diaphragm descends downwards with
our full lungs our pelvic diaphragm
moves upwards so we're essentially
giving our organs a nice beautiful hug
squeezing out all that lymph and I want
you to visualize this beautiful light
rising up through your spine as you're
squeezing your pelvic floor
visualize it rising up through your
abdomen
through your chest through your heart
through your throat and through the top
of your head and keep holding
keep holding and whenever you feel ready
to I'm going to ask you to hold as long
as you can you can probably keep holding
comfortably to keep your tongue at the
roof of your mouth
and you let it out with a buzz breath
nice and loud and proud and slow so very
slow whenever you're ready you can keep
holding
and once you
gone to the bottom of that buzz breath
you're going to hold on empty as long as
you can
keep holding and I want you to just
visualize that light filling up your
body
filling up the cells in your body with
this golden energy
keeping your intention in mind
create hold
a little bit louder
there you go
let it all the way out
all the way out at hold at the bottom
and let's come back to your normal
breathing pattern of six seconds in six
seconds out
find the pace that's comfortable for you
great and this is something that you can
repeat so you can go through this
pattern several times okay back it's a
great way to you know amp up your body
to feel centered to feel present to set
a beautiful intention and it took us
about seven and a half minutes to do
that let's go my my hands are Ting yeah
I got really hot today yeah it's
supposed to happen yeah we can use our
breath
to send blood flow to different parts of
our body recognize our breath to raise
our temperature we can use our breath to
raise or lower our blood pressure
so what you did there is you we went
through kind of a cornucopia of
different breathing techniques that will
alter our physiology so you can't raise
your body temperature without creating a
shift in your mitochondria yeah right so
this demonstrates that we've just kind
of energized our body in a very profound
way yeah I mean it's already hot in here
with my hoodie on and a lot and then
like I'm gonna pass out I gotta take
this off but then all the microphones
connected and I think Deepa many laughed
they do mini laugh in the middle of that
thing no I don't know if I'd have heard
a laugh then I almost lost it
all right well we'll leave us with an
intention then what you know it's been
an amazing session together how do you
uh want to end this with an intention
for the audience yeah well thank you
what for this opportunity you know I I'd
love for everyone to find their breath
and really come back to it throughout
the day and and use it as a tool for
their own inner healing their inner
peace for better sleep for better
intimacy and for whatever it is they
want to do the better we breathe the
better we get at everything whether it's
productivity whether it's athletic
performance whether it's being more
responsive instead of being reactive in
a situation whether it's better you know
performance in the bedroom or whether
it's even better performance in the
boardroom like it all depends on how we
breathe it's so simple which doesn't
always make it sexy but what's cool
about breathing is that we can actually
see improvements very immeasurable
improvements very quickly like you know
something happened right your body
temperature change your hands may maybe
sweat more your hands are tingling right
so you know that there's something
happening and and so that's what's
beautiful about it is we can see
measurable changes in people uh in a
very short period of time I always
remind people that if you want to feel
better in 30 days change your diet if
you want to feel better in a week drink
more water if you want to feel better
tomorrow get a good night's rest but if
you want to feel better today then the
only thing I could really think of that
gets us there is our breath because we
can't go even five minutes without
breathing
but many of us are either over breathing
which is more common than under
breathing and many of us may be
dysfunctionally breathing which then
leads to a dysfunctional nervous system
so the yogis and the Ancients have known
this for many many years it's baked into
every ancient culture that breath is a
technology that allows us to create
profound shifts in our healing and it's
available to us we don't have to invent
anything we don't have to go to the
store and buy anything there's no
subscription we just have to do it and
and commit to it and we'll see
differences you'll see differences very
very quickly I love it Sachin and Deepa
where are people going to find you
a few places they can go to become
proof.com and learn more about our work
they can also go to 30 and
30.org which is a free 30-day program
that we've set up for people we share
our 30 best health tips as if you were
coming to see us in our Clinic these are
the things that you should know so you
don't need to come and see us but if you
still do then we're here to help and
we're here to serve and and help people
get to the root cause of what's causing
their illness and ailments or what's
preventing them from Peak Performance
amazing great work thank you my friend
we're coming in thank you thank you and
she did it to see my one-on-one
breathing session with Wim Hoff check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there remember deep
breathing is able
is able to change the biochemistry
Insight deeper than ever thought
possible I want to teach people